ny
家が好き花粉と申しますこの間久しぶりにねワンみました
ポリロートというかたくさんの言葉を話せる人たちの会議に参加しました
福岡で
日本のかアジアあるいは色パフェからいろんな人が
たくさんの言葉を話せる人たちがそこで集まりましていろんなテーマはおもしろい
テーマについて話が
私ますしまー
演説しましたけれども
それでまあ日本のその英語を勉強の事情についてちょっと調べました
こういう本が買えました
そういう例もたくさんありましたけどね世界で一番心配な
軍法の
嬉しいですけどね
かっかあさんはご視聴そうだけれどもこの本を読んでもいい
洋画
解説を浴びじゃないんですよね文法の説明を見ても
対して営業はないのです
もしその文法の説明の議場がすでに自分が
分かっていれば
気が付いてれば
まあその説明が自分がすでに経験したものの過去になりますけれども
説明を見るから
じゃあこれから
この分母を正して使えるかっていう合奏じゃないんですよ
言葉でその進歩するにはですね
一つの一つ方法しかないんですそれはたくさん読んでたくさん聴いてい
たくさん読んで聴いて後で自分の思いが増やしていけば
自分のそのなじみ言葉の私な子に
私ごとば考えず宮出来ていれば
少しずつゆっくりと
進歩するんでしょ
脳がいつもん
覚えますよ
覚える日階ですけれども
行く位そして
スキーな順番で開くらしい
分母あったし言葉の構造
ただ一つ買う
本が磯用近藤できません先生が教えたから
あるいはこの本で読んだからじゃあすぐ直しましたとそういうことじゃないです
で今
私の場合は今
まあご八かの言葉を話せるんですけれども
今あなた語大賞のトークを勉強しますそして新しい挑戦でね
まあいえば極端な言語学習法というか
毎日必ずこの3つの言葉を勉強する
そして毎日書く言葉ごとに約タルゴ
100単語を開発
開発課技術で知られる次女といってもそれオンラインですから
普通の実証しゃべるのは非常に二回かがあるから
そして秘書で調べてものはすぐばせますから
だから我々のリンクシステムで
その知らない単語が青色なんですよ
その青い色を
俺前の辞書で調べて
そしてやはり
システムのデータベースに入っちゃうんでしまい脳の中のデータで気に入っちゃいます
勝負はしています
また出てくる
次に出てきたときに今色がヒーローですけれども
何回も出てくる
何回も出てきた後で行っ東その新しいタウン
あるいは二人いつも同じですよプレースを保存しますシステムね
そのフレーズは何回もなんかに聞いて読んで
dart んどう
脳の中の人
データベースだけじゃなくて実際の
使えるところに
は馬を築いていた
0毎日約書く言葉こと200
そうすると一つの言葉を勉強している
皆さん
その場合が多いと思いますがん
毎日300単語を保存することができるんですよ
それだいたいまあ1時間くらいなんです
なんかもちろんそれのその
知らない単語見つかって調べた
ミートベイシティでどう一家そのその摘出そのもの子やまあもちろん読んでそして
アウディ遊びに関連した青でを聞いて
そうしますとその環境
言葉も保存しててキスを読んでそれもまた
前によって何回も聞いて
車の中
[音楽]
私のバイブ
朝ごはんを作る時に
サラはライフやる時に
ちょっと運動する時に聞きます
そういうような
しかし毎日だから
昨日はですねえ
ちょっと調べたら
登録簿では50したなかった昨日
ぺー車道とアナゴは約やりましたけれども
覚悟ばも無事して泣いたもう夜10人あるだけでもやらないとになると誰そういうあの
目標がねぇ
目標は英語で
その何か言っといて
投げなくに
改善したいと連絡したりとそれは具体的な目標じゃないんです
それを自分がコントロールできないんです
私はもっと上手に
竜所に英語を話したいという目標ではあるんです
なぜかキュッとする根拠はできないです
毎日約館の山びゃく巻号
保存したい
それに関連した適当
なよいいよ未来日以来
それは具体的な自分がコントロールできる
あの
東方ですねー
行動
五十里が本当に毎日やれば
私前
9ヶ月間走いようと思っています
100巻号程度100看護やろうなキャル
作曲単語
んだろうそれが
久月さんですねもう25000以上の
看護を
いわゆる保存数
その意志ナンバー節カー
自分で使えるその合意になりますけど何パーセントになるか知りません
コントロールできません
15日米うち知りません多分今までの経緯があるぞと
たぶん2割3割ん
しかし私今今日できるそう
極端まあ
言語逆手法は毎日毎日必ずもう100の略
307300単語
保存しますそれは林でありますけれども皆さん好きな
その
勉強実戦で顔のこれをやってください
まあそれは僕は提案する
極端な言語学商法
ご意見を聞きたいですじゃあまた
次へ
水のどけ
マイ中
40 b をやろうと思います
[音楽]
ん
んっ
[音楽]
た